artists day 2 at PAX East and Alexa we
just got a demo of a game that I've been
waiting to play for about eight years
now me too and it was Final Fantasy 15
finally finally episodes SK she
clarified the demo that will be out on
March 17th
yeah with Final Fantasy type-0 and I
know your big final fantasy fan as am i
but I'm curious to hear what you thought
of it what was probably one of your
favorite things about the whole day um I
saw a wild chocobo yeah I got a tugboat
there's a check for ranch I really like
that G world is very open I know it was
something that they were talking about
earlier it feels like you can and I
think you can go literally anywhere that
you can see like you have a big expanse
of fields you have a forest and you have
a road along which there's the ranch and
I think the mechanic yeah please do
thanks where they get the car done
whatever jacket um no there's just a lot
the world feels very big and it feels
very lived in I liked that there were in
a wild animals running around when you
run through the grass the grass what's
wait for swallowed life out of the way
there was a really great stealth
sequence in a misty area with a giant
behemoth it was just the world itself I
think it's my favorite part
is there anything that maybe caught you
off-guard you're like I didn't expect it
to be like that I'm not sure I like that
I didn't expect there to be a lot of
party banter I mean I'm really sort of I
warming up to the characters from Final
Fantasy 15 and I really liked that while
you were running along and while you
were maybe seeing something in the
distance or someone would shout
something or there would be an item drop
a few feet away and keep sort of like I
would try to ignore it and walk by it
and one of my party members would go hey
not to check this out and not just be
like what like the party banter was
really really good they really feel like
the friends I like it
there was once I know where that
happened where he's like hey look at
this sign and I looked at the sign he
goes great job knocked as you totally
did it
like that's a little nothing okay that's
another top but ya know there was really
good chemistry between the characters
and even though we didn't really get a
robust introduction into you know their
full background how they know each other
and stuff like that I did kind of get
the sense that I was going along with a
group of my friends you know there is a
lot of stuff in combat where they're
calling each other over for help
or just going to help one another out
you know for me I spend most of the
demo2 sort of running around and
exploring the world and it it is sort of
it's big but it is a limited area like I
got to the edge of an area where I would
say you can't go too far wait for the
full game but at the same time again
yeah like the different locales that
we're there we're great
you know at one minute you're in the
wilderness the next minute you're where
people are like lounging like drinking
sodas reading the newspaper you go up to
a counter and the guys know what can I
do for you like more than pass Final
Fantasies where it's like you're in a
store you're going to go buy something
this was sort of like a store within an
environment that wasn't a full town so
is that nice middle ground and I'm
curious to see the interplay between
exploration and going through these sort
of you know these living societies yeah
speaking of you know exploration and
combat and stuff like that you just
reminded me I really like the cooking
mechanic I was a little skeptical when
they announced it and they were like oh
like you can cook and it'll the old game
experience points and buffs but if you
make like every different dish you make
gives you like a different set of status
buffs like I think I ate some sort of
like katsu and
gave me like immunity to a poison or
something and I saw you were cooking
something completely different and you
got like a fresh boost or something
getting more fresh but I think that's
really interesting and that also depends
on like whether or not you hunt
if you don't hunt you eat toast did you
notice that I know I didn't if you have
no ingredients to make anything it's
just four guys sitting around eating
toast it's really funny that's cool yeah
well there's so much to say about Final
Fantasy 15 I mean I know it's just a few
weeks away we finally get to spend more
time with the game but in the meantime
outside of this video we've got a bunch
more stuff coming on the way from Final
Fantasy and from pack seats to stay
tuned to games.com